thoughts on this deal to start with just
signed well it's too little too late the
conservatives have had years to get a
grip of this issue it's welcome of
course that they're now speaking with
France in a more constructive way but
they're talking about the patrols going
up from 200 to 300 and yet the number of
interceptions needs to go up from 42 to
75 to actually make a difference and
break the business model of the people
Smuggler so the jury's out on whether
that's going to work and it doesn't get
to the heart of the issue which is a
massive backlog in our Asylum processing
system with over 10 000 Asylum Seekers
waiting more than three years and that
is actually acting as a pull factor for
the people Smugglers and people trying
to come over on small boats because they
know if they get here they'll be years
before their claim even gets processed
so that's the real issue at the heart of
this we also need to see far more
resources going into the National Crime
agency so that they can work up stream
and break the model of the people
Smugglers working Upstream we would pay
for that by scrapping the unworkable
unethical and unaffordable Rwanda scheme
um okay but what would you do about
trying to stop them coming across the
channel in the first place because of
course the 2K agreement was a labor
agreement with the French the treaty I
should say
um that's not worked well the heart of
this issue is the broken Asylum
processing system that's a magnet
because so many of the people's mugglers
and people wanting to come across know
that they'll be here for years before
their claim even gets heard so we would
resource the home office properly so
that they can clear that backlog so that
it's not costing six million pounds a
day to the British taxpayer to put
Asylum Seekers into hotels clear that
backlog and I think a lot of the pool
Factor would go in addition resource the
National Crime agency properly we we
would put a hundred Specialists into a
new Elite unit working with Europe and
the French and the belgians and others
to actually break the people Smugglers
model Upstream there's none of that in
this announcement the government has
made today it looks really like more of
the same so uh Robert was right then
when he said that people are coming over
in order to stay in nice hotels
well I think people are coming over for
a variety of reasons let's not forget
that 75 percent of those who come and
claim Asylum their claims are successful
and they are given Asylum but there is
certainly a percentage who are coming
here as economic migrants and they
shouldn't be claiming asylum on that
basis I don't think there's that many
people who dream of being left in limbo
in the British system for years and
years but there are many of course who
Melt Away into the underground economy
and they seek to make new lives for
themselves we but we cannot have a
system where people are claiming Asylum
when they're not legitimate Asylum
Seekers and then they're just staying in
the system for years so that's
fundamentally what needs to be sorted
out that's the hard yards the
nitty-gritty of getting government right
but we've seen this revolving door of
Chaos in successive conservative
governments I think we've all lost count
of how many home secretaries we've had
how many prime ministers we've had and
when you've got that kind of chaos it's
little wonder that the home of lost grip
of the home office and they've lost a
grip on the Asylum processing system
talk to me about ID cards you suggested
it I believe was quite a good idea and
then your boss the shadow Home Secretary
said absolutely not I think if you look
really carefully at what I said it I I
was saying that it's obviously an idea
that's been looked at and debated but it
is not a priority for us and the vet
made that very clear so there's no
difference between a vet and I on that
point which is that it's
look I the it's not a priority for us
now um the the key thing for us now is
to look at the broken Asylum processing
system get the National Crime agency
sorted out have a proper deal with the
United Nations High Commissioner for
refugees so that we can have safe and
legal routes for for people get our Aid
System working back up to 0.7 so we can
actually stop some of these issues at
source those are the top priorities
um my comments in that interview were
about an idea that's been around for a
long time but it is not a priority it's
it's simply not a priority for us now
just to get it ID cards are a way of
registering people and looking at a
system which ensures that you've got
clarity about who is here and who's in
the country and one of the things I said
was of course after the brexit
referendum we had issues around the
number of EU people that EU citizens
that were applying for settled and
pre-settled data but that's not really
the issue that we're talking about right
now which is about this deal with France
and how whether or not it's going to
stop asylums and I just wondered what
whether you thought it impacted on
people's human rights or whether as
tomorrow put it to me in the office this
morning
um you need to give most of your
information
um if you're buying a wardrobe online
anyway so does it actually make any
difference well has Yvette made clear
the issue we have is there are lots of
forms of ID in this country National
Insurance number you know put passport
driving license but they're not being
enforced properly so we're not having a
with the situation needs to be where
employers and landlords and others are
actually asking people for ID and
checking they are who they say they are
we need a single enforcement agency in
this country at the moment there's a
kind of alphabet soup of different
agencies that are enforcing all of this
let's get the enforcement right let's
get the Asylum issues right and fix our
broken system that's been broken by 12
years of conservative incompetence and I
think the conversation about the ID
cards is a conversation for another day
are you saying that there's still a good
idea though aren't you talk to me about
um the Autumn statement the longest
serving Health secretary that we've
known in modern times of course was
Jeremy Hunt who is now the chancellor
um do you think he will look favorably
on trying to salvage what's left of our
poor Health Service
well we certainly hope so
um we understand that spending on the
NHS will be protected of course spending
has to go with reform
um but what you fundamentally have is uh
you need to have an NHS which is
underpinned by a strong economy and
after 12 years of Tory failure and then
12 weeks of complete chaos with the
disastrous mini budget uh people have
just lost confidence in the government's
ability to manage the economy and so
they're boxed in now they're either
looking at these tax increases or yet
more austerity and public spending cuts
those decisions those choices are
fundamentally because they have failed
to manage our economy and they have
crashed it in the last few months with
um well I mean reports saying that that
mini budget cost the British taxpayer 30
billion pounds it is absolutely
extraordinary so the NHS is not safe in
their hands the British economy is not
safe in their hands that's actually why
we need a general election because we
have a prime minister that doesn't have
a mandate and they have failed to give
the British people the confidence and
the trust that we need to have in our
economy moving forward that means a
proper long-term growth plan it means
Fair taxation it means closing loopholes
it means stopping non-dom status it
means removing the all of the loopholes
for the big multinational so labor
putting forward a fair taxation uh plan
and you have to win the general election
before that we certainly do do you think
that Jeremy corbyn should be allowed to
stand as a labor MP
I think that care has made it clear that
Jeremy's comments after the report on
anti-Semitism were not in line with our
values and he therefore had to remove
the whip from Jeremy corbyn and um if
Jeremy and Kia can come to an agreement
whereby Jeremy apologizes in the correct
way for the comments that he made then
I'm sure that Q would be open to having
that conversation because Kiera said
that himself but Jeremy has made it
clear that he's not going to apologize
and I think that that um really leaves
us in the situation that we're in so the
answer is no he shouldn't be allowed to
stand unless he apologizes I think there
has to be a very clear and fulsome
apology should be all right stand as
mayor of London
well if he's no longer a labor MP
doesn't have the labor whip I guess
Jeremy corbyn is a free agent and is
able to to do whatever he wants to do
but uh I think what's absolutely clear
is that we have an outstanding mayor of
London inside Khan and uh you know I'm I
I'm sure that Sadiq would want to uh
look to the Future and make sure that
London is in the hands of a labor mayor
who's going to actually continue to
deliver for the people of London exactly
what he said half an hour ago when he
was out there good to talk to you thank
you very much it is great to see you